good morning folks.
We are live.
Hey Pepe. Missed the snow up here. Yep.
Thankfully.
Uh, okay. So, let's see. Yesterday I was
just messing around a little bit with
the end speed tests.
Let's uh What on earth is wrong with my
Okay, let's just real quick get a new
term.
Uh so yesterday I was messing around a
little bit
with
the environment profiler. Uh we made a
little bit of progress. Fixed one pretty
bad bug.
I It was just a stupid bug.
And it was a bug that Claude caught.
That tells you how stupid of a bug it
is.
okay. So, we were looking at the Mspeed
yesterday. Uh, I'll show you what I
built real quick with this.
Mspeed
breakout.
Uh first of all single. So this is to
match the uh single threaded PF.
Okay. So we have 147 mil single and then
we can do
direct
which is uh using our threaded API I
believe
and I believe that you take a little bit
of a
right?
One was this one zero total agents one
zero one. Oh this is zero threads. So
yeah this is uh this is without
threading
and then 8192m
horizon horizon doesn't really matter
and then 24.
So now this is with 8192M. So way worth
cash coherency.
It should be 80 something mil.
Ah, that's not good.
Huh?
I could swear I had this working
yesterday.
we have this to 80 mil yesterday. I'm
trying to remember if I have different
RS
Well, we may or may not want to mess
with this right now. Let me think if I
want to do this now. um because we
definitely have stuff to do on the end
bindings. So I guess the things that we
can work on today, we have a whole bunch
of new networks to port over and things
to profile. We have environments to fix
bindings for. We have the mspeed
profiling. We have kernel changes from
um a contributor to merge in
and other things than that. There's just
general cleanup.
I think that this is a good thing to
work on right now though. So, if we can
get our vectorization to be performant,
if we can actually have all these tests
passing,
we should see a nice speed up as well.
So, yeah, I'll invest some time with
this. Well, I'm sort of
not still waking up, but getting my mind
on this. So, I spent some time this
morning reading the Dumb Dario article
and it's, you know, I've kind of noticed
that the like smart writers who write
[ __ ] every individual paragraph
uh that they write will be fine and very
difficult to object to.
Uh, every single one will be very
difficult to object to. But if you then
take the thing as a whole, it's
[ __ ]
All right. So, what's going on with
this?
Oh, it's on GPU. I'm dumb. Okay. Yes, I
have it correct. Watch this.
So test m speed breakout 8192 ms. Yeah.
Uh one buffer
uh wait is it one buffer zero threads
horizon
block says one CPU.
I was doing GPU transfer with that.
Good. 80 mil.
So, um, it goes down from what was it?
120. No. Uh, yeah. 120 to 80. Now, this
is with no threads.
And now, if I put this on a background
thread,
so now there's thread synchronization
overhead.
Yeah. So 8 mil. So that's like terrible,
right? But now if I put the block size
up to something reasonable, we we
amortize the threading overhead
and we're at 70 mil. So not terrible,
right?
And now if I do
four threads,
270 mil.
So that's pretty darn good, right?
That's like linear scaling to four
threads. I think it does get worse if we
try to do like 8
and say 512. I think this will be
substantially worse. So, I don't think
it scales like infinitely well,
but we'll have to figure that out later
at the Yeah. See, so for whatever
reason, 8 threads doesn't actually seem
to help. We got linear scaling up to
four. We'll figure out the rest of it
later. So now the question here
if I put this to GPU
uh actually I don't know if this is
going to put it on GPU
40 mil. Yeah, just don't let's just
confirm we go down from 250 mil down to
40 mil.
So that's a pretty big head. So why
don't we figure out
So I think it's 119 or yeah 119 floats
time four bytes is 476.
And then if we assume 32
actually we can just do it this way. 32
gigs. Oops.
Is this correct?
So if we have 32 gigabytes
of uh bandwidth, is it 32 or 64 for
PCIe?
I want to see how close we are to
theoretical limit. Um
PCIe bandwidth.
Okay. So, how do I check
32 or 64?
Check PC with
Is it in here?
Daria's going totally next level.
What? Next level ridiculous. Maybe
it's just paranoid propaganda.
I read the whole thing in bed this
morning. Um, long ass article.
I do think that the guy actually thinks
he's doing the right thing.
He's clearly not, though.
This says that we are Gen 5. So, we
should have 64 gigs,
right?
then we're not remotely hitting it,
It should be 134 mil. SPS should be the
cap.
So, the fastest that I could
theoretically get um this running should
be about 134 mil.
I just need a very like a very quick
bandwidth test to make sure we're
actually hitting something like that
cuz there's the hardware spec listing
and then there's the actual number that
we can hit under optimal conditions and
then that's the number that we want to
get close to.
Car pathy tweet.
Are you kidding me?
Man, is this going to be decent?
Cuz I think everybody just needs to shut
up and get back to building stuff. It's
just yap yap yap yap yap.
This is true.
I mean, he's not completely washed, but
he's still a bit off base. I think he's
pretty close, but a bit off.
This I think is bad.
No.
No, this is not true. This is not true
at all.
It's close enough to be like almost
there, but it it's like it's crucially
wrong. The thing that he's wrong about
here, so the reason that the that the
agents feel so useful and the reason
that you see me using it so much here uh
is because existing code bases are ass.
All right. So because I right now I have
to deal with uh the C environments which
are good but then they have to be bound
to C++ via CDLs. Okay. And then I have
CUDA kernels and obviously CUDA. I have
launch functions which that's how CUDAS
works. So you have redundant launch
functions. There's the CUDA to C++
barrier and you have to have headers
across that that are very redundant. uh
libtor torch itself is absolutely
disgusting and awful and the build
system is incredibly slow. So it's very
very difficult to quickly iterate
manually just because of the compile
times. All these things together make it
so that whenever I want to make a change
I have to go make a change in like five
to 10 different places and I have to
keep four or five different APIs in my
head. Um yes the agents are good at
dealing with that but this is bad right
like the code should not look like this
code should be it should be designed
such that it is efficient for a human to
work with and by the way that'll also
make it better for the agent to work
with and faster anyway. So it's just
strictly better.
So in some sense the less effort that
you put into making the code good less
agency you yourself will have over your
code bases right. So, this is the thing
I actually don't like about these models
is that they reward you being lazy
because they give you more of an ability
to deal with your lazy mess of code. But
that's not what I want to use this for.
Right? So, what I'm essentially trying
to do here is I'm using this writing a
bunch of throwaway stuff to make sense
of this entire mess that I have
inherited from Torch plus their stack
and how they integrate with CUDA and
everything else. And then my goal is
that at the end of the day before this
release I end up with something that is
nice and concise and compact and very
human friendly. Right? That is the
difference. If you don't do that last
step, you are trolling and you're not
actually building something that is
going to be long-term useful.
Knowledge is not suddenly free because
here this is the thing 20. I can tell
you everything I know. I have all these
RL guides, right? I mean, I charge
companies a lot of money for the stuff
that I do, and the prices keep going up
every time I release a new update to
Puffer and we have new capabilities. So,
why isn't everybody suddenly able to do
this? There's a difference between me
telling you something and you
understanding something, right? And you
need to actually understand the thing in
order to be useful and effective.
confusing world. Yes, it's very
confusing. That's for sure. So, my
general advice is yes, you can use the
models, but use these models to make
sense of the mess out there and to
understand and to simplify and to build
things, not in order to think for you.
here like here I'll let me like write
this and let me show you why I'm using
it this way. I will explain to you
exactly
Uh there does have to be.
Does there have to be any device
synchronization?
uh, why am I doing this like this? Um,
actually, to be fair, this is me being
lazy because I was thinking like, ah,
there are a bunch of annoying CUDA APIs,
but they're actually not. The thing
that's annoying here is just the um the
build script more than anything.
Well, let's see if this makes a mess of
it.
This is a throwaway test though.
Regardless, Dario is at least a bit
honest. Uh he is he's misguided.
I put him above Altman in the sense that
he's more honest and um he's smarter and
more honest than Altman,
but I I think he's very misguided.
I mean, in general, like the anthropic
people are incredibly out of touch.
See, like, why the hell is this test so
damn long,
right?
because it did this extra thing I didn't
ask for.
We're off and ignore and build stuff.
It's not where the profession is headed,
dude. You can literally just turn the
thing off and build stuff. Hey, Antonio.
Yeah. See, lo and behold, this is not
remotely how I would have written this
test. This test is really crap.
Uh, I'm going to take this test, but I'm
not going to include this in the repo.
I'm just going to run this as a
throwaway to just see real quick.
I I really just need a a lower bound
more than anything.
Yeah, it's really stupid it did it this
way.
Holy,
that's really stupid. I did it this way.
time seconds.
Yeah, it I don't know why the hell it
would do iterations for this
So, it just ran the test for less than a
second.
bytes 1 MB.
We have um 4 * 118 * 192 186.
We're going to do chunks of it's like 3
to 4 megabytes
in practice, right?
Actually, uh with buffers, it'll be 2MP.
2 megaby bytes.
Yeah, Mo, I've honestly I've been
happier. I've been spending less time on
X and more time working and on Gillanor.
That's what I've been doing in the
evenings.
There's just so much stupid noise in AI
right now.
40 gigs a second.
Yeah. Look at that. 40 gigs per second.
It consistent
What's it? Megabytes 14
20.
There we go.
I wonder what happens if I put like a
slightly off number, you know,
37 gigs.
No, Kilanor is the Runescape continent,
my guy.
I mean 42 is I actually I don't know how
hard it is to actually hit um how hard
is it to hit PCIe bandwidth? Does
anybody know?
Like what's the realistic
okay.
So it's the synchronizations
cuz the me copies are very very fast
right?
publish paper.
Uh, I don't really need to publish
anymore, man. Unless I'm on pubs that
are like collaborations with academic
labs, it's mostly a waste of my time.
Yeah. Okay. Okay, so we're only hitting
40 gigs.
It's like a 5second test.
Yeah. So these check should be fine.
this 4 MB.
We'll do 8 MP maybe.
It actually doesn't seem like it has to
be down synced.
Oh, of course not. It's aligned. Oh,
okay. So, that it does actually increase
Then you get 10k its.
I wonder if it's this stupid um
get. It's probably this get time in
seconds, right?
this is fine.
Yeah, it's nano. Okay. So, it's not
that.
be blocks.
Yeah, it's not faster.
I mean if that is the practical
limitation though of what we have unless
I'm doing something wrong Here
Can run the following to install. This
looks good.
It's very important that we have a good
baseline.
It's worth um taking a little bit to
make sure.
Uh this is basically we just want to
make sure that we have an accurate
estimate of how fast our thing could be.
Hey user
failed to detect a default CUDA
architecture.
Really?
I think I probably just have to set this
flag.
Files have been written. Okay.
Can you make it fit in L2 CAD?
Uh What's the cache size? And shouldn't
it do that automatically if it fits?
Wait, why could that even matter? It's
um it's a pure bandwidth test.
This should be testing PCIe speed,
right?
Ah, there we go. Look,
this is the exact same as my test, Gabe.
Well, I mean, this is possibly a setup
issue with the machine.
PCIe X8.
Oh,
wait. I lost PCI.
Oh, wait. I lost PCI. Hang on. Let me try this.
Hang on. Let me try this.
Want
is not in pass through.
That could be well I don't see it on the
host device though
unless this rep is wrong.
Should it show up in D message like
this?
device.
Is this the 5090? This is right.
Uh, I can set this up on the host real
quick. It should show in D message. It
doesn't. I see group 14 here.
32. Wait, why is it 32 GT?
Eh.
Oh, that is five.
I don't know what GT is
default. If it is in PT mode, it should
show.
So then what should I do? Should I just
set up this test real quick on uh on the
host?
Let me set this up on the host then real
quick. That should do it, right?
I did check it on the host. I didn't see
it.
Ah, shoot. Okay, I don't even have cuda
on. Yeah, cuda is just on the um That's
annoying. I forgot about that. Let me
try one more time.
As you said, this should show in D
message
this, right? This should work.
Not there.
Wait, start what kernel?
Oh, the OS
is not enabled.
Okay.
So then why is it slow? Where are we
losing our per?
It's not on the wrong socket. There's
one node.
We don't have that anyways. Okay. Well,
there's a hardware setup quirk. We don't
really need to worry too much though. Um
because uh the hardware is what the
hardware is. It does mean that we should
include some sort of little memory bin
with test with puffer,
but we're capped to about 48 gigs
at the best.
So, let's go let's go look now. Um,
and let's just like see if we can get
the code to be near the hardware cap
at the moment.
Okay. So
the 119* 4
so 48 gigs divided by about this much
bandwidth.
So this should be 83 mil should be the
cap.
Yeah, 83 mil should be the cap. Oh, and
um let me think because we have
Let's go double. Let's go check our test
again.
46GB. Okay. Okay, so this says that we
should be able to hit uh the pretty much
the peak with these settings. So, this
is pretty much the hardware peak here,
and we should be able to hit it with
this size of a copy.
Four threads
and one
We're looking for about 80 mil.
Let's go to 8192.
Two buffers.
Okay. Well, that's faster than it's
supposed to be able to go.
Yeah, that is faster than it's supposed
to be able to go.
Though not faster than the hardware is
supposed to be able to go.
Possibly we did something weird with
double queuing it.
If I do four buffers, does it get
better?
Okay. So, that's faster than it's
supposed to be able to go. So, then the
test is wrong. That's annoying.
What are we doing today? We're trying to
get accurate profiling information on
our vectorization and we're going to try
to see if we can get our vectorzation to
be about as fast as the hardware
bandwidth.
You see like I believe um
if we were to do like 48 divided by
this is the GPU drive one.
It should be able to get to 6 million.
So yeah, our VE is slow at the moment.
Yeah,
I see the bug.
when you wait what? It depends on the
problem.
Typically, one of the easiest things to
do is just think about what would happen
if you were trying to build the game for
a Game Boy or the environment in general
for a Game Boy.
That'll get you a nice action space.
Obsace can be tricky though.
Doesn't work for everything as well.
Some things are very difficult to put
into a nice action space.
It's very important to do it though.
Yeah. So, this is no longer going to be
a bajillion steps per second, right?
Okay. That gets us 50 mil, though.
Okay.
50 mil up from what? 30 mil.
What about with two buffers?
46.
What if we do uh 16
buffers?
We're basically going to play with this
for a bit until I'm convinced it's like
problem or like this is how it scales. I
I just want to play with this for a
little bit.
Okay. So, there's going to be one buffer
now.
How fast is this building? CPU
writing. I've started writing it, man. I
have not finished it yet.
>> in particular. So, it bothers me that
this doesn't work.
Oh, no. That does work. It's You get
diminishing returns, but it does work.
Okay.
I do 16 threads.
I mean we get over 200 mill steps per
second vectorzed.
Okay. So you do actually crush it um
under a certain point.
But this uh this is quite nice.
So what if I now go to this four buffers
I mean the more I use the model the more
I think like it's really not smart. It's
really pretty dumb.
like the oh you know the elite engineers
are you do like just having the model
write all their code. It's actually like
it's really the dumb engineers are
having it write all their code and the
good engineers are having it like appi
apply basically glorified refactor and
reformat things.
It's really not doing all that novel of
work. It's really just good for the
drudgery. So like, okay, automating all
the drudgery to be able to program stuff
faster. And I'm still thinking about all
the hard problems at the level of line
by line code.
But of course, you know, they take that
and they just like
completely
lie.
You can't make it do anything hard if
you want good. Yeah. No, this so scar I
use it for
I mostly use it to apply templating if
that makes sense. So I have this piece
of code over here that looks like this
that came from this piece of code over
other over here that looks like that.
And now I have this other piece of code
like that and it needs to be ported over
to this thing to look like this. Right?
is pretty much like um
pretty like straightforward unambiguous
refactor ops.
It's just that I have a lot of those
right now because of what this current
project is. So it looks like it's very
useful, but generally it's nowhere near
as much.
So like am I going to be using this for
everything like everywhere? No.
Okay. So, we get 53 mil.
Uh, we should be hitting 80 mil.
Okay, so this one is fync here and then
vec receive.
I'm going to comment this just for a
second because I think this could be it.
Oh, you have a synchronized in here,
dude. Hang on.
Yeah, you have it synchronized right
here. Of course, this is a mess.
only up to 54 mil from that really
back threading.
H.
If I go back to more reasonable
settings.
Okay. Yeah, that was not the play.
Don't let me forget to undo this, guys.
It'll break stuff.
I got to have um
I just want to make sure we don't have
any other weird
weird operations in here.
Like there should be no
synchronizations.
The mem copy. Ah,
wait. CUDAM copy.
Oh, that's fine. That's on startup.
That's pretty much fine, isn't it?
Oh, you know what? Let's There's one
other thing I want to try. Hang on. So,
we said that this one is not the uh the
bottleneck, right?
[snorts] 267.
So this is what 5x faster. So it should
be like 20% overhead
How about we do the drive end? The drive
end will be more interesting, I think.
Ah, this might be um
too much.
Eight agents,
one buffer,
zero threads.
Says eight on CPU.
Can we do this one?
Well, this will be the thing that we
have to figure out. Let me use the
restroom real quick and then we will
continue on this. Grab a cup of tea as
well.
Okay.
Yeah.
This is with random movements
1.1 mil. Right?
If I just do this
Okay, you should be able to at least get
it over a mill.
Just to make sure the time is not going
to screw us up the time call. I don't
think it does.
done much with Majoko. Oh jeez, man.
Majoko MLCO.
If you want the slowest damn simulation
ever, then yeah, sure. Have fun.
Wait, what?
Is this stupid?
Is it like completely stupid?
yours ready for users
and hardware integration. Ready for
users. Yes, we are not a robotics
company, man. We're an RL company. We do
general purpose RL.
If people want us to do robotics, then
sure, we do a few things with hardware,
um, lowdimensional hardware.
drones,
but it's not our main business. We do
general purpose RL.
Most of our stuff is very heavily
focused on like um enabling stupidly
fast simulation and then enabling the RL
loop to keep up with that. So, Puffer 4
is going to be above 10 million steps
per second training on one GPU.
And you can do a lot when stuff is that
fast.
Make sure I'm not misounting.
1.1 mil.
Something is different between these
two.
>> Uh, it's like, okay, the risks due to
engineered nano particle swarms are all
so mass I can just make [ __ ] up as well.
as it does not recall. Yes, it does.
They've actively supported major
restrictive legislation repeatedly over
the last several years.
whoops. So, it is just a dumb bug.
This is why I don't let Claude write
tests, even a really basic ones.
Oops.
This should still be 120 mil.
That's just social media, dude.
Literally, all of them are like that.
And yes, it is based on [ __ ] that you
click on.
If you just click not interested on like
10 of those posts, they'll go away.
It's like I click on one Runescape post
and now I've got 20% Runescape in my
timeline, right?
You don't even have to like the post.
Just clicking on it is enough.
192.
One buffer,
Oh, wait. There should be one other
test.
do this first
for a few weeks. No. Well, I mean, in my
case, it's directly tied to my business,
so it's a bit different.
Ah, okay. So, this is another story.
Look at this.
This gives it this massive haircut to
performance somehow. You see this?
Now, this is consistent, I'd say, with
our earlier findings, but that's like
really big. What if I do 256?
Is it really just like screw up caching
that bad? Is that what I'm seeing?
Is it? No. 256 doesn't fit in the c
either.
PCI
this is a mix of things. So, we're
testing both uh CPU speeds and scaling
and then also PCIe.
Hit me up when you want to integrate.
Oh, okay. Awesome. Let me uh let me
finish this thought and then we'll
integrate your PO kernel stuff.
All right. Well, I can take a break from
this to go on the uh the kernels because
those are going to be a nice win. Let's
go take a look at what you got. Pull up
the new
This is peruse stuff. Oh, yeah. Folks,
please star the puffer on GitHub if you
haven't already. It does help me out a
ton. It's absolutely free.
Okay, I'll look at that later. I I'm
pretty sure this is wrong, but we'll
double check it.
Okay, let's go find your stuff. I was I
got distracted because I was so weird.
Uh,
fix issues. Tensors were not contiguous.
Colonel does square root.
Okay.
This is the profile file. Let's go look
at the other one.
I see. I think you could simplify this,
but you know, I can simplify this as
long as it's correct.
Just Yeah, let me get this board. Hang
on.
Lovely. We got the uh the CLI Disport
updates.
It still does that.
Where am I looking for messages?
General or dev or something?
Where' your thing go? here
strides. This is what I would expect.
And then you put the square root into
the kernel.
Okay, this is what I would expect. Was
this seriously the only issue?
messy, but if this works, I'm very, very
happy with it because I can clean stuff
up as long as it is correct. In fact,
I'm probably going to do all day stream
Thursday cleaning stuff up if we get
Perf to be good by then.
I can merge this directly actually.
Solid PR
blah blah blah blah blah checks failed
don't matter urge
DM deal
okay except DM
need the strides main variance auto
single kernel launch
introduced it's kernel
Wait. Oh, torch has varmin. I didn't
know torch has bar. That's cool,
dude. Thank you. This is sweet. Let me
uh let me rebuild this.
I mean, I got so close with this colonel
and I was like, what the heck is wrong
with it? I wonder if it's You said
training stable, though. So, let's see
if we get training stable.
The annoying thing is there's probably
still some very small numeric stuff to
deal with still, but
If this works, I have plenty of other
stuff you can do on here.
Oo,
that's over 11 mil right there.
Uh, we are not getting any stats back,
but hang on.
I think this is me screwing it up. Hang
on.
Stuff l This is stuff what? Yeah,
exactly.
Uh I did I don't think it's I don't
think this is your bug, man. Yeah, I
think I broke something with this here.
Let me figure it out
cuz I've been messing with the end
builds.
I did rebuild though.
Ah,
well, I don't know why this would break
yet, but um
get up to four.
Oh, there we go.
Oh, I think frame skip set to zero
literally does nothing then, right?
Okay, so we don't get 11 out of it.
There's um there is environment in the
loop. What did you get 12 mil out of,
man?
It was when it jumped at the end. Ah
okay. But when it jumps at the end for
me it jumps to like 25 mil which is the
eval speed. Eval speeds should be way
faster than train speed. Say like 25.
Boom.
Hey, that's still a solid contribution
though. That is um that's a nice bit of
speed.
That cleans up um
that cleans up our kernel calls as well.
Makes profiling easier.
And you have it here. Yeah, this is
good.
Yeah. So, one thing we were
experimenting here with Jonah
I think you could premp compute this
over the entire batch rather than just a
mini batch. But that is something that
we'd have to ablate I suppose.
is there more stuff that you would like
to do? Because I could always, if you
want stuff to do, you could always try
out BF-16.
I actually Hang on. Is there a way that
you can write a matrix output to a
different DT type?
Just cast it.
Well, no. A cast is a colonel, dude.
So, you defeat the point.
Cast are colonels.
Is this all it does
in the kernel? You cast it. It's too
late. If you do it in the kernel, man,
the point is that you um if you do it in
the kernel, you've already wasted the
memory bandwidth, right? So, the point
is that the inputs going into the kernel
will be half the size. inputs in BF16.
Yes, all computation can occur in FB32
and just downcast at the end. Yeah, so
that's what we would want. We'd either
want that or we do the mattles in BF16.
So for the kernels, that's what we want
to do is inputs BF16. But in order for
that to make sense, we have to be able
to handle the mats without having
redundant casts.
Let me see if I can look into this a
little bit and then either I start on it
or maybe I can give it to you if you
want, but I want to see if it's actually
doable.
Yeah. So like this pattern here, you see
that this pattern is bad, right? Cuz
that like you've already wasted anything
that you would save, you've already
wasted.
I think you'd have to do it manually,
right?
Yeah. You see I was doing do you see
this thing that I have at the bottom
here? This sync FP16 FP32.
So like one thing that I could see doing
uh Jonah would be
here.
Tell me if this makes sense and if you'd
be interested in trying this.
So like the problem is the maples,
right?
So you have like
maple
gate.
So one thing you could do
uh is you can do this can be
so inside this map right
you actually have
32 and then you have W6.
Oops.
and use W16 for the mat moles.
How does this work for training?
Does this work for training?
Yeah, it does work for training. And
then when you do the uh the gradient
updates, you use this one. And then in
between gradient updates, you sync these
two back and forth.
uh in between gradient updates.
Would that do it?
So then that should cut your that cuts
your memory bandwidth in half for all of
training at the price of doing one
additional weight synchronization for
optimum step.
The question then is going to be is that
faster and is that stable?
Like the key here is that this is
already in 16, right? And then the
output is in 16 and then the gate gets
16. It does internally it does 32 but
that's not incurring like the uh the
memory bandwidth for the inputs.
How your weights are stored throughout.
Yeah, that's why I wasn't going to use
torch autocast, right?
like this is how I did it for this one,
right?
Because I was playing with this before.
So you just grab the two policies. So
you just make two copies of your policy,
right?
And you just iterate through the pram
and you do this copy underscore.
So this should be zero. Let me see. Is
this zero kernels?
It's slightly annoying because this
every single one of these casts is a
kernel. Like if you were smarter about
it, you could technically have it be one
kernel.
But this is not bad. It's one kernel per
weight.
It'll get cudographed anyways.
Decided to write some M's. Just worked
through the full Flappy Bird game.
Looking for a larger project to do.
any suggestions or things that would be
useful?
I'd have to see how the Flappy Bird code
looks. Generally, the best thing for
newcomers to do is to then if you've
done that, then write something that's
more of like a reasonable arcade game.
I wonder how hard Crest would be.
Okay, I got to be a little bit careful
with you because like some of these end
up being way harder than you would
expect.
A lot of the Atari arcade games are
good, like good newcomer projects if you
just pick one that looks reasonably
simple, that hasn't been done, and that
has already been used in a bunch of
papers.
Aim for something that you can do in
like, you know, 4 to 600 lines. A second
project.
Goal is to have weights and input stored
in 16 bits and then all computation in
32. Well, you can do you can do it
either way, right? So, you could do I
think that the gates should stay in
32bit,
right? There's not really much benefit
to trying to do the gates in 16 bit
anyways. So, all of our custom kernels
uh should be the computations in 32, but
then this does open up the possibility
for us to do the mats in BF-16 with the
tensor cores. uh that should be
dramatically faster
especially as the net sizes get bigger.
So what I would expect is you get some
benefit to doing that with our current
net sizes. But then the cool thing about
this uh should be that if you then let's
say that we do 512 hidden dim everything
should get way faster. So this update
would actually
it's not going to make a huge difference
I don't think. Uh well hang on the
memory bandwidth will make a big
difference for small models but then
doing the computation in BF16 would make
a large difference for bigger models
because like I don't know 509D
where the specs
It's bigger either way. I forget how
much, but
you know, BF16 should be much faster
than TF-32.
So, let me reopen this chat window
because my doc broke somehow
there.
Uh, if you've said anything else, Joan,
it hasn't showed up. I just see your
Discord message. chat's being weird.
But yeah, that would be my my next
suggestion
and go back to doing end of debugging
unless there's stuff to discuss on that.
Is my YouTube chat full broken? No, it's
not. I think it's okay. More questions
as I'm looking into it. Sounds good. I'm
here all day.
Yeah, I think that's probably the last
major optimization. That and the end
stuff I'm working on for 40.
That'd be so funny though. We end up
getting like 15 mil.
The thing is I didn't get a huge benefit
from BF16 before, but I think it was
because everything else was so
inefficient. You know, mattles were a
very small fraction of the compute time,
but now that it's quite a big fraction,
it should be better.
Let me actually try something real
quick.
1 mil, right?
With no ops.
2.4 mil.
So,
it's pretty much on par with what you
would expect.
Still thrashing pretty bad.
It's not even iterating over the ops
though.
Wait, is it? No, not as bad actually.
Now,
I can do this myself.
Yo guys, is the chat working? I don't
know if my chat's broke. Let me go check
YouTube
It gets Mstar, right?
How about I do like this?
Okay. So, what I'm going to do here,
right, is now it's going to step all the
M's and then compute all the obs. And I
just want to see if this makes a
difference with the caching somehow.
It's probably worse
to load everything twice.
about the same. Well, no need to do that
then. Uh, it's just caching.
Okay, so now we know that the drive M's
actually kind of slow.
Now let's see how much faster we can get
it.
do this and we're going to start doing
uh a couple tests.
one buffer,
zero threads, 64 horizon
CPU
slower environment. We should be able to
parallelize more.
It's probably just doing too many loops,
right?
Let's fix this real quick.
You know what it is? Where's the uh the
telescope and blind? Was it telescope
and can
be
this one?
Where's the
Okay. Yeah, it's this freaking meme,
right? It's like there are multiple ways
to lie about stuff. You can you can
still lie about stuff while writing
things that are entirely true, right? If
you just devote 90% of the attention and
hype around the like small like uh the
downsides and then 10% on the really
good upsides, you've still completely
misrepresented everything without
writing anything that's technically
directly untrue. Right?
smarter but
uh manipulative people will do because
then it's very difficult to like call
them out directly because they haven't
lied about anything. They've just like
set a bad narrative so to speak
and that kind of requires understanding
what they're doing. Actually,
the more I think about it, the more it's
literally the 2027 playbook, right? It's
the exact same thing. Gigantic essay
with about like 90% madeup downsides
that you can't technically refute as
impossible and then almost nothing about
like, oh, also this could be the most
positive thing ever for humanity.
It's the same thing.
Man, it took me a while to actually draw
the connection as well because like it
is well written and it was a
dramatically better executed piece than
the original one. The original one was
like it was well written for masses, but
it was still sort of a sloppy hit piece
on AI. Um, this one is like
way more intelligent and I think more
sincere as well, though maybe it's just
very well crafted. Um,
it's still all bollocks though.
Why does this thing take so long?
Oh, because you did the wrong one,
dummy.
Wait,
Oh,
you've got this as well. Right.
Yeah. Like this
I think I need to get better at doing
that as well, like at pointing out.
I got to make that. Maybe I'll just post
that later.
This takes How's this still take
forever?
This is weird.
Oh, because you're stupid. You keep
doing it wrong.
Why? Yeah, I'm I keep doing it wrong.
Damn it. Okay. Yes.
Yes.
There
should be better.
So click test. And now
we can start looking at scaling.
Right?
Yes.
Good.
First test one thread.
Okay. 43. Still good. Buffers will go up
to four threads.
that scales absolutely terribly.
Why is that the case?
If I do breakout,
does it scale the same?
Oh, this is also slow.
Why is this also slow?
blocks. Wait
name
buffers
threads.
Something is very weird.
SPF
Basically just need to get this to feel
consistent.
Yeah, something is completely messed up.
What did I do?
locked in. Hey, off market. I have no
idea what the heck is wrong with my
reream chat. It's just not working here.
I still see it on the stream, but I like
my dock I normally have is just broken.
That's okay, I guess.
Let me use the restroom real quick. I'll
be right back. Man, this is like the
annoying thing with profiling. You have
to be so incredibly careful with these
Okay, I got a couple ideas. I got a
couple ideas.
Hey Jess, I'm trying to get uh some good
profiles on our vectorization
and see if we can figure out where
things are fast or not.
Uh well, just it depends. You might not
need one.
Sweep SPS
specific. Yeah, but that's the thing.
You may or may not actually need that in
the new version, Jess.
Like a lot of the stuff that felt jank
with that was jank because of PyTorch.
You can watch our agent play chess as
well if uh Jess has that.
That's absolutely stupid as hell.
[laughter]
Why you don't reply to
change any of this though. I'm trying to
think what the heck I could have messed
with.
people. Yeah, it's a pretty dumb
comparison, frankly.
I mean this is just like impossible,
right?
Thank you.
That's what I forgot to change back.
Finding dense rewards don't help. Seems
terms are sufficient. Yeah, the RL is
pretty good. Jess needs a lot of data
and a decent neural net.
Okay, this is not going to help us very
much unfortunately on um on the rest of
stuff, but
uh 8192
buffers will be one
one buffer
uh one thread 64 for
12.
Why is it? Oh, no, it's not. I'm done.
Okay, this is totally fine.
Got to actually remember things. Come
on.
Like having to
make sure I'm not forgetting. Okay,
good. That is what we want.
Drive like this.
checkers and getting 100% win rate.
That is good.
Checker's kind of easy.
for the buffer.
Okay, so this scales terribly right now.
Let's go to frame skip four.
Oops.
I don't think that does anything on the
CPU.
CNN alternatives better seeing the
results much better learning but is slow
the encoding for chest is probably sort
of weird.
Okay, let's first of all let's figure
out why this thing is so freaking slow.
liking the glasses. I wear them when I
don't feel like putting in my contacts
for the day.
H.
This is interesting. This is way too
slow.
Ah, there we go. 27 mil
about D and debug.
25 mil. So, we can leave D and debug
04. Yeah. No.
and 03 is slower than O2
is normally what we see.
Okay. So now we get a reasonable number
speed single.
Where's M speed single?
Yeah, that's the first thing I tried as
well.
All right,
And now we run it with the reasonable
args.
It's eight even faster. Is it even more
work?
We only get about 2x faster.
Okay.
But if I do drive,
and actually this one I need to do,
let's do 100. 100.
Yeah, because we can't have um
we can't be having these crazy numbers
here.
Really, this does not scale very well at
all.
So, this deck is um not performing as it
should.
Really not at all.
This should be like stupid fast.
Okay. So, I mean, we don't even need to
do uh drive for this, right? This is
just like
not doing what it should.
on eight cores.
Yeah, like no matter what you set it to,
it just does not scale.
That's not good.
Well, let's make sure that the amp speed
test itself is not to blame.
Make sure it's not these device
synchronizes. Oh, okay.
Uh, it is the device synchronizes to
some reasonable extent.
Wait, I'm on CPU, dude. What?
Wait,
wait. What?
That should not have done anything.
Why did my test just randomly get way
faster?
I mean, it's still nowhere near where it
should be.
That's where it should be. And then
what? It just doesn't scale.
Yeah. Okay. It doesn't scale above a few
threads, it seems.
I honestly don't even know. Do I believe
that? Hang on.
Hang on.
There's what we get from the direct
profile.
So if I now go
to four,
Uhuh.
Yeah, it's not working right.
This is very annoying as well because
like
this should be an amazing amazing back
implementation.
Are they just fighting over too many
atomics? Is that what it is?
I mean, I'm giving it quite large blocks
of work.
Do you have to give it like way bigger?
Threading is just like the worst thing
ever, man.
I mean, this is just really like not a
very good vector implementation.
Frankly,
what I can say,
this does not scale well at all.
64 to 128. What, dude?
This is very disappointing. I mean, I
wrote this to be like the awesome VEC
implementation.
I mean, we're going to have to like
profile this and figure it out.
Yeah, I've tried both, dude. I've tried
You can go through for low as well.
Like you get way more overhead if you go
low. I have 16 threads. I should be able
to use them.
Yeah. It's you get to 27 mil with this.
So, I don't understand why there is so
why it's so so much slower
uh with that many more m like you should
only be able to be so bad in your
caching, right?
I just want to make sure we're not doing
some like stupid cringe stuff.
Okay, this is the 22 mil from before,
right?
Oh,
okay.
huh?
Well, we found something, guys.
Somehow the DLL is injecting this like
weird latency.
Huh.
right,
I'm use the restroom and get myself
another mug of tea and we'll figure out
why this is doing absolute [ __ ]
Okay,
I got Mrs. Toast as well.
Yeah, it's going to need all these.
We'll let it mess around for a bit
though because it basically
we have the problem. We just have to go
try a few things.
So that doesn't help, which is good
because that would be really screwed up
if that was the memory layout issue
because we can't do anything about the
memory layout in practice. It'll mess up
the copies.
So we're happy that that's not the
issue.
Yeah, I got to stop doing that [ __ ]
That's really bad,
right? Interrupts your train of thought.
Um,
but right now I'm mostly just being
pissed off by DL's being weird.
like I've already found the bug, right?
Like I found the um the issue
and now it's just a matter of isolating
it, which takes a bit, but like we have
it like uh we're pretty clear what's
going on,
you know?
Oh, that just makes it even faster,
funny enough. Huh. There's
not that.
Where the hell did these args come from,
man?
Dude,
I had no idea
where these came from.
Is there anything right here? How on
earth did this get wrong?
Must have let the stupid LM auto
complete. Jesus.
God, that is so bad.
Oh my god,
that was so stupid.
Okay, we're still 20 mil though.
Hang on.
What about the initial
paddle width? Initial paddle width.
and the single test.
Yeah, the arcs were all messed up.
Let's go check the multi one just in
case. I think this one should be more
stable.
I do think that this one should be a
more stable test
there can just be like weird little
caching differences.
Everything is so tiny.
And then the exact same state is
allocated.
Good.
The thing is I'm suspicious that
something is not scaling correctly.
Well, this is hang on.
So, this should now be 14 15 mil.
Okay, this is still the same speed.
goes up to 40 mil
and just stops scaling, right?
Yeah, it's it is it looks like threading
contention, but I thought that I
optimized that
like it should be very low overhead.
Wait. Threading completed.
I think this is a mess. Let's see.
Actually, you know what? We should just
be able to do
Yeah, because we really want to like get
a a test where we know that it's
Oh, okay. So, you actually do crush your
perf
uh when you just have a ton of atoms,
huh?
Okay, but then this should be easy for
testing. Now
if I just do
okay 5.9 Now it's the same thing. Right
now we go to four.
I I don't understand how this scales so
freaking terribly.
Taking too big of a hit for having a lot
of ends.
Hey, this is way better than the other
stuff that's been putting on my
timeline, right?
Shouldn't it be shouldn't the
scheduleuler? So it should scale to 14
then.
You bench 500? No.
There's not a single person in the world
that looks like I do that benches 500
lb. Dude, are you kidding me? My best
was 265.
at the moment. Can still do a few reps
of two plates.
I did a set of five a couple weeks back.
I'm trying to fix a shoulder injury
though before I try to like push the
weight too much again.
I mean, it really should be easy to get
better scaling than this.
no. All right. Even if the mutex takes
forever to acquire, like we just have
really big blocks.
And also this time here, this processing
time is also per block.
So I don't actually see how it's
possible for this to not scale.
Okay, we can do Well, we can watch Htop,
I suppose.
Well, hang on. Wait. Why do I have all
the cores, these cores at 100?
What? Why am I seeing these cores at
100?
Okay.
Um, I don't think I even have that set
up.
Geeks for geeks. Where is the stupid
thing?
Do I not have it?
Is it this?
Okay, this thing is completely stupid.
Um,
yeah. This thing's completely freaking
stupid.
I mean, it's not scaling anywhere near
as well as I would expect it to.
It's very sad though that that's better
than my implementation out of the box.
scaling due to memory and cache.
Okay, so it's both.
Oh, duh, you idiot. It's going to be me
bound.
3 32
the scale to 32.
Okay. So, it doesn't just go to like the
number of ends times the number of
threads, right?
So, the most we can expect to get is the
25 mil.
Okay, let me try with the drive.
Actually, this is kind of interesting.
processing
open MP.
They don't, but the map does,
unfortunately.
This does mean heavier MS will scale
better.
It's just GPU drive isn't compute heavy.
It's memory heavy.
It's the problem.
So, I mean what this means is we need
some tests.
Yeah, we'll just make a puffer end.
We'll do like a synthetic puffer end
>> Mhm.
Yeah. I I'm going to just like skim
through this because
I think what we have to do uh we need to
distinguish between computebound and
memory bound environments
and we need to have tests for both of
those.
What time is this two already?
I also don't want to work on this one
thing all day all day.
I'd like to do something more manual as
well, not just this crappy like
throwaway test with Claude.
Maybe that's what we'll do is we'll do
um
yeah, maybe we'll do like an actual
proper test
um for the that.
Yeah. So, this see this thing just made
a complete mess.
This is why you don't do this. This is
exactly why you don't do what I'm doing
right here.
This What the [ __ ] Awful. Like awful.
Awful. Awful.
Yeah. So, this test is basically
worthless now. It's gotten clotted to
the point like this is um indecipherable
garbage code.
Yep. There you go. Okay. So, this test
is broke.
Uh, I'd like to say
That's actually a perfect example of why
you don't do that. It wrote a whole
bunch of garbage and then just broke it.
Yeah, this is just all undoing things.
Cool.
Okay. So,
what have we learned? Um, from what
we've done today so far, we fixed a few
bugs. We've learned
uh
there's definitely a fundamental scaling
limitation.
Uh, we've learned that I should have had
a synthetic benchmark end a long time
ago. So, we can isolate membbound versus
computebound. Uh, I've learned, though I
should have known this a long time ago,
incredibly stupid that when Ms get this
fast, uh, them being mem bound does more
than just make them slow on transfer to
GPU. They also fight each other when you
go to thread them.
So, that was kind of obvious, but man,
I'm going to take a few minutes and I'm
going to reset a little bit and then I'm
going to come back
and
uh what we're going to do is we're going
to write like a synthetic N that is
either
just like a th does nothing or is
incredibly memory bound or is incredibly
computebound
and then what we'll be able to do is
we'll see how puffer scales in all three
cases
right I'll be right All right.
Can't you slashre back? I didn't know
that.
Whatever. We're going to do our own
thing now anyways.
Let's get all the requireds out of the
way.
Okay, so this one will actually do
something
Actually, we can even do we can do
better.
We can just do band
with
How do we get something that's not going
to get optimized out?
Is there something better than tanh? Are
there like um hash functions?
Do I want to do this in a loop or the
mess set?
Okay, there's your basic end,
right?
Start
long steps.
This is fine.
Yeah, there you go. That's actually a
really expensive ball.
Yeah.
So now you can, you know, you can crank
it up to 100 signs.
Don't really need to warm it up, do you?
CPU benchmark.
Yeah, that's fine.
Bandwidth is
stupidly massive.
Wait, how does this make sense?
Uh, this cannot be right, can it?
No, it's just not doing it. It's like
optimizing it out.
Result equal equals zero.
Yeah, but it shouldn't be able to catch
that. Right
now I I just did this. Right. I didn't
think I could cache it though because
it's it's not compile time. Like this
compute variable is not compile time.
Uh this is it can't have infinite
bandwidth.
Puffer six. No plans for puffer six yet.
Y yet, Jess.
Like, we'll make it, but I don't know
what it's going to be.
Presumably, we have a heck of a lot of
stuff solved by then.
There we go.
Uh, this is again still too much.
It's like the compiler is doing
something weird.
Okay, I think we can do this then,
right?
Yep. So now we get 50 gigs if it doesn't
fit L3.
Cool.
Okay. So once you go above 63. So this
is what was happening basically, right?
is we just had the entire test for some
of these fitting in L3.
You go down to 50 mil,
but hey, that's pretty cool.
Reream is kill. I may have spammed you.
Thought my messages were just being
eaten. Your messages were just being
eaten.
Um, it's they're not showing up
correctly. I have no idea why.
Restream's been screwy today.
Like, I see your messages on the chat
window, Jess, which wasn't working
before,
and I don't see them on the screen above
me, which usually that shouldn't be
possible.
Something's super broken.
Find an alternative. It pretty much just
has to hook into OBS and um connect to X
uh Twitch and YouTube. People have told
me I should try Streamlabs. I might just
do that.
I think that's annoying because I don't
think it's a plugin. I think it's like a
replacement for OBS. And OBS is the
super stable thing that actually works.
What in the hell?
Absolute freaking goober.
Why do you need to
Oh,
Is that do it? Yeah, you have to do like
this.
right to 320 mill steps per second which
is nice
Okay. Very nice.
One thread
still nice and fast. Perfect.
Four threads.
It's four times as much.
Eight threads.
No more scaling.
Okay. So now we have
0.1
mill steps per second.
Not quite 16x.
You get 14x. It's not bad.
So, ideal workload,
you get 14x.
That's roughly the speed of our
environment, right?
All right. So, this is roughly the speed
of our end, right? So, now we can go up
to four.
16 goes up to 241.
So you see what I'm doing here is like
I'm getting us these best cases.
Um
so because like now what we can do here
let's now we can basically simulate um
we can basically simulate breakout
exactly because
all we have to do
118 so it's like 480 bytes I believe
that's breakout right there
we can see it should actually be able to
be um it should be able to be reasonably
quick here.
Now the problem is we also don't know
all the other right patterns.
So this is still kind of synthetic in a
way.
I mean, but this fairly small workload,
it looks like it's supposed to be able
to scale decently. Sorry.
I think more realistic would just be to
like run
Yeah. So I think what we want to
basically be able to do here,
so we want to be able to just run
OpenMPP
on our environments
and 190 mil is the max end speed that
can be passed. No, we're not even on
past GPU, man. We're not even on that
yet.
Okay, I have some ideas for how I want
to handle this. Then
let me
uh let me go get a mug of tea and we
will figure out how to work through
this.
Well, I have some ideas to do what to do
with this.
This is a nice little benchmark,
honestly.
Let me think a little bit about my
architecture
because
I'm trying to figure out what the hell
is wrong with me. Like what was I doing
with all of this?
Well, I guess what I don't understand is
what does OpenMP do.
Why did I not know about this and just
use this?
Like, am I stupid?
It's probably some super basic thing,
right?
every is okay
directly to cuda target. Wait, what do
you mean you can pass directly to CUD to
target? What does that mean?
Well, I mean, my dumbass didn't know
this existed.
Well, I mean, I knew OpenMPP existed,
but I didn't realize it was literally
like um
I didn't realize it was something this
simple, right? I thought it was going to
be some very fancy, heavy library that's
a pain to integrate and that makes you
change all your code.
This is basically like mat lab par4.
Actually, Mat Lab Parkour probably just
calls this exactly
Well, this would give us a reason to do
autotune.
Right. So the thing is you still need I
still need something in the background
to cue the um
the vectorzation transfers. Right.
That's really the complex piece of it.
So I I'm not like a total idiot. It
wasn't just like oh you should have just
done open MP or whatever because there's
the additional complexity we have with
the transfers.
I don't know what you mean. You can
directly pass directly to CUDA target.
Maybe you don't.
Well, you would need a manager thread,
right?
when I was messing with CUDA if see if
you find it. Yeah.
Okay, so this thing is completely
[ __ ] stupid.
You still get CPU GPU local app? No, you
[ __ ] don't.
I'm so confused. I think it's just
insane.
Async completes during the next buffer
step.
Ah, okay. Okay. So, it would do
I see what it's doing. It's It's
actually That's kind of clever,
but it's still bad.
Are your workers idle waiting for the
GPU?
Yeah, this design is this is completely
stupid. This looks super simple, but
this is completely stupid.
It like pretends to be smart.
I mean, this is like it it took me a few
minutes, you see, though, to figure out
that this is ridiculous.
It's like, look, code.
Okay, let me think of the other thing
that Peru said.
Was it the one other thing
Yeah. So we I mean we do this
multi-threaded GPU patching
Was thinking of open MP target but just
makes it run on GPU.
Huh.
There's nothing in here. Did he not
commit the code for this?
I mean, it looks to me like he didn't
commit the code
cuz I don't know where on earth this
would possibly be.
I do a PhD.
I never tell people to do a PhD.
You should do a PhD if you want to do a
PhD. I don't ever tell people, "Oh yeah,
go do a PhD.
Call forward eval batch to run
full BPT across all segments.
Wait forward
batch.
I'm so confused. Like for this has good
results. I have no idea how
So what do we do with this? Because like
we have this whole optimization where
Peru says he has this thing super fast
here.
I don't think I can even pull this out
easily to test.
Well, let me think of let me think of
there's a simple way I can do this. So
I mean, he's just like queuing up
everything.
Let me think about this.
I think I can probably
I should need to go. Actually, I need to
go double check one thing because I've
missed.
Let me just double check one thing and
then I can fully focus on this.
instead of doing this.
This just becomes the OM call.
Well, the problem I suppose is that now
the
you don't want to thread the PyTorch
call, do you?
That's I think that's the problem,
right? Is I think that's why it gets to
be complicated. You have to thread the
PyTorch Paul.
I The only thing is you have to put the
freaking torch call into this.
I'm trying to figure out why this is
even supposed to be a good idea.
I mean, it's like just basically Peru
told me so.
I like I under like I fundamentally
don't understand why this is a good
idea.
if the GPU is slower, then by the time
you're ready for more data, it's there.
I have no idea why this thing is good as
like as much of a speed up as he says.
And then you just make two back ends,
right?
Oh, not really.
You could still do it in one.
Yeah, I think this is worth um worth
trying.
We'll just uh we're going to make a bit
of a mess of this, but
we can try it this way. It'll keep the
same interface.
We can time it directly.
Yeah, we'll see on this.
Here's the restroom. I'll be right back
and we'll do this. Another hour, too.
create threads. Okay, perfect. I
actually can literally do it right here.
Okay. Okay. So now instead of um
C thread manager
takes the back end.
Yeah, it needs to know which ones it's
responsible for, right?
And now in place of the manager,
we're going to do here.
It's going to be much simpler, I
believe.
Yeah, it's going to be tough to get the
pietor torch net into this. The only
annoying thing
Do I give it a function pointer?
Magic function pointer.
Think that I have it. Like I think it's
it's not that hard if we just do it this
way.
I think there is a CUDA device
synchronized.
And then you're done,
right?
Something like this, I think, could
work.
Several MS is
quite bad. So, you do need to reuse
these.
Uh, I think I can get Claude to do this
from here though because it's literally
it just needs a couple of flags.
If I'm careful, I think I can get it to
fill in because I this is the chunk that
I wanted to write myself.
I think it is this simple.
Let's see if it's smart enough to do
this. I think
I mean, this would be so much easier if
we can do this.
Like, so much easier,
right?
There's literally one screen of code.
Yeah. Well, I mean, honestly,
Carpath is at least more correct than
most here. He's slightly off base with
some of the LLM stuff,
but at least his takes are nowhere near
as stupid as the average Twitter user.
I actually I think I'm going to do this
different. I don't like what it's done
with the void type here. I think I'm
going to cast it in there.
Okay, let's see what it's done here. OMP
thread manager
Okay. Okay. I don't like what it's done
here.
Vex send.
This is fine.
Yeah, this is completely wrong. Nice
job, Opus.
This is what I mean. Like I can get it
to do it if I pay attention because
otherwise it makes a total mess.
But it's been a while since I looked at
this and I think that this integration
it can do easy enough.
Okay. Void star call. Yep.
I don't know if that's the right syntax.
That's weird.
That might be correct. The void star.
That's just weird looking. I never do it
that way.
Why you get rid of my C stream
synchronize?
Okay, this is fine. Just change to call
this from um
from the test.
If this works, if we can get this to
work.
Yeah, if we can just get this to work,
then we can test out the speed dips and
we can get a very nice answer.
Okay, that's good. Actually, we do it
first with this.
So, we see if we didn't break anything.
So, first we make sure that this still
works.
Damn it.
Uh, hang on. Let me Docker stop. I hate
like stupid Docker just drops drops Cuda
randomly. So annoying.
So this one runs right. This optimizes.
This is good.
Now we build the torch
and this should be calling the same
code.
Okay, we did not break anything. That's
very nice.
It's going to be a Little gross with the
function handles
initially.
I think it can actually be a single
function, right?
because I basically You just take the
entire loop, right, or the entire
contents of the loop and you stick it in
um an opaque pointer.
That's fine.
Do it like that.
These are very small little things. So
pretty much the plan is we're just going
to hand this thing a pointer that's to
the entire net forward pass and copies
including the graph logic.
uh and then the rollouts will just be
done in that. So we'll just have like
one call per buffer
and then that actually does it the way
that uh Peru is doing it now even
so we get additional parallelism
potentially
and then we'll see if the training
matches per and if it's faster.
Yes, this is fine.
Yeah, this is fine actually.
I think it's getting confused where this
is getting called from.
right. So, let's try this
cuz now this should work.
So, this should still be using the old
path.
Okay, this is still using the old path.
Good.
it's not going to do the same thing,
dummy.
In theory, this should work.
It's really freaking janky for now, but
I'm hoping if I can just get this end to
end and test it tonight. I mean, that
would be great.
Barring synchronization crap or like DLL
crap, um,
it should just be fine because it's the
same op.
It actually has less room for sync to go
weird.
I see what's wrong. Why it's getting
confused.
Yep, this is fine
again. Very hacky.
Good enough for testing.
Yeah, this is exactly what we want. So,
it's basically you flip a flag at the
start.
Yeah, exactly. This super freaking
basic,
but
the fact that there's this bit of
synchronization now, the synchronization
is outside of the loop over time.
should make it way better. We will see
Mhm.
That's better.
Um
yeah, kind of a weird day with all this
stuff.
If I'm correct though, then the
the function in the C++ should look very
simple.
Wait. Vec om step. You can't pass it a
puffer, dude. Wait. Can you pass it
pufferve?
Uh this create red signature needs to
get updated.
And then this is going to have to be the
function pointer
and create threads gets updated and then
we are good.
Yep. And I got this
create threads. Uh
That should be ve shouldn't it
should not be paparall wait true
use
Oh, actually fine. It just did it weird.
Uhl.get
It's a really stupid way of doing it.
We'll have to clean that.
I don't even know if that works to be
honest.
Weird C++ things.
Okay.
on. Yes.
Yes. Ethan,
that runs
interestingly.
Okay, it trains sort of.
That's not what I was expecting.
Why are you creating threads? Because
it's buffered.
It's more complicated than just one
layer thing.
I believe it uses threads internally as
well.
I don't know if it actually is
processes.
sign reward. No, it's not learnable.
Wait, where did you even see that on my
screen? Oh, you didn't. I'm sorry. I was
doing I did something else with a
sinosoid for a dummy. And sign of reward
is learnable. Um, what?
I don't know what sign of reward I like.
You mean if the reward is a sign
function, is it learnable? If you can
observe the time, then yeah.
Or if you can observe the reward, that
would also work.
following.
No, no, you were asking something else.
I think I was doing I had a sign and an
end earlier, so I thought you were
asking about that,
but that was something totally
different.
Does it work with one buffer?
Yeah, it does, doesn't it?
Uh oh. Yeah,
it's not a photographs thing.
It's a buffer thing.
Yeah, that's my bad.
That was really stupid of me.
That's totally what it is. I don't know
how I forgot that.
Well, I know exactly how I forgot that.
There's a million bloody things going
on.
Okay, fine. We'll do it this way for
now.
What what was on your mind that day?
Um I I don't know. I thought it would be
fun. I streamed some games for a bit for
fun uh while I was doing my PhD once in
a while. So I like I figured a you know
this that was kind of fun. Let me see
what happens if I just stream my dev
work.
I figured like maybe it would give me a
a way to like narrate my thoughts out
loud. I thought it might help me focus
and it ended up being very enjoyable.
I feel a bit exposed. You think? Not
really. You get over it very quickly.
I mean, I do stupid [ __ ] on here all
day, but I get stuff done.
So, I mean, the idea is just like, all
right, if you're so much better at
everything, then be my guest. solve RL.
Until somebody else decides to do that,
I will be sitting here bumbling my way
through it.
Not really. It's not as I get as
distracted on my own as as with this
dream.
So it's really not any sort of time
loss.
Yeah. So you just need per roller.
That's fine.
There we go. This is fine.
But I want to separate in a moment. I'll
have to separate this one. But
I mean, we'll see if this is even
faster.
It is actually quite a bit simpler to be
fair in some ways.
buffer raking money. I mean, we're
profitable already.
We are lining up a bunch of contracts.
Um, a couple new contracts at least
quite soon.
We have active ones as well.
There's going to be so much stuff to
freaking clean up. I think Thursday is
going to be clean up day if I can get it
to work today.
Yeah. So, basically, this is just having
to do an extra set of traces.
It's not even really an extra set of
traces, though.
Like the copies, it's the same number of
traces. So, really, the only thing that
you have to do a little differently is
you have to trace um they're two
different intermediate buffers. now.
What the heck is this doing?
Ah,
I see
graphs at zero. That's totally fine.
That's exactly what I would do to choose
it.
Or else next thing society should value
They will
I mean, I think it's going to be very
profitable. It's my secondary motivation
for sure.
Dota on a 4090 in a weekend. What would
it do though? Dota on a 4090. So if Dota
were I think that if we could get Dota
to run on a 4090 in a weekend given like
a really fast Dota sim and optimized
architecture, how much how many steps
could we do with that? Let's say that we
got that running like a pretty small
model
at like a few million steps per second.
Let's say 10 bill an hour, 240 billion
steps. You might need more data than
that to be fair. I maybe with
algorithmic advancements. Look, if we
could solve Dota in an in a weekend, oh,
240 bill per day. So 500 bill. If we
could solve Dota in like 500 billion
steps with a tiny model, um
I mean that RL would be substantially
more powerful than any of the LLMs these
stupid companies have because you
basically just point it at some sort of
fiddly unintuitive optimization problem
and it will insta solve it. So like yes,
oh like oh haha it solves a game in a
weekend like that. No, what that
represents is like completely superhuman
intelligence.
That would be absolutely insane. You'd
pretty much just be able to hook up any
problem you care about to a like in a
fast sim and it would just solve. Are we
at stable alpha yet? Jess, I'm trying.
Maybe Thursday.
This [ __ ] is hard.
We stable at least.
Okay. So, this one is stable. So, now we
have an alternative vec back end. Uh, it
is slow though.
So, let me go look at
let me go look at the synchronizations
that we were doing before.
five bill what are we what is the
distance to that
um
so with puffer 4 I think we'll pretty
much have the speed for that with these
small networks
uh there's probably a pretty big
algorithmic gap though to being able to
solve problems that hard that quickly
that's going to be puffer five objective
and we also need like actually hard
benchmarks attempt attempts to throw
this at like we do not have a version of
Dota that just runs super super fast. So
in some sense if we had more
environments that are hard but have
smooth progress curves and that run
really fast that is directly helpful to
research right
you streaming Wednesday. No, Jess. I um
I've been doing like Tuesday, Thursday,
Saturday. Wednesday is probably going to
be Well, I've got uh one doctor's
appointment. I've got a couple calls.
I've got um a big gym session. And then
I probably got to fit in a little bit of
client work.
This was my attempt from when I was
brand new to see
it's literally the Dota map one for one
ported in like this is the Dota map.
It's just kind of like it's kind of
simple. And it turns out that if you
don't have selfplay solve for this, then
you'd actually need a good scripted
opponent to play against. And also like
the move sets I put in are kind of too
simple and stuff. But this is a pretty
decent base and it's pretty quick.
Yeah. So once we have selfplay that's
stable, Jess, we could probably revisit
that moa end. Like that's a pretty good
starting point.
So wait, we synchronize before send.
No, single thread synchronizes.
Okay, so this one is just an async copy.
And then there's no
there actually no synchronizations in
here at all.
I think we can just put one device
synchronized ball.
It's before send. What's that mean?
Uh, right. It's just we don't know.
Okay. So, it's right before send.
So, I think then
on
transfer actions.
Yes. This is the only one that we need.
Just a device synchronize
and then
you do have to synchronize the stream.
your name sounds like [ __ ] [laughter]
He's got you there.
Each steps to attend sequentially. No,
you absolute [ __ ]
We also have multiple schedules and
things to play with.
Uh, this is still way slower than
before.
Uh yeah, it's not doing it.
It's not actually using the threads.
950 is probably better than I am.
Actually, he's definitely better than I
am.
still no
it's not just slow it's not vectorizing
correctly
Yeah, but we're not doing search, Ethan.
That's the point.
The point is we're not doing search
known ELO opponent.
We have to use a no point and a runs
that ran longer. Yeah. So that's the
problem, Jess. Like there. No, you can't
automate that smartly. You need a known
ELO opponent to ground it against,
right?
Search plus RL. No, because search is
freaking slow. That's the problem.
No. Yeah. But the thing is like the
point of what we're doing is not to do
that. The point of what we're doing is
to see can we do it without the search
because search scales like [ __ ] It
doesn't work on the vast majority of
ends. Um, and it is always slow and it
is always a total pain in the ass.
that's nice.
Well, that matches speed with our other
implementation.
Well, we can play with this now because
um
I this matches the speed of our other
implementation.
Let's just make sure this is doing uh
what we expect.
Uh the search is exponentially
expensive.
So the question is what have like what
if we just run the network way more
right?
Like why do we need search when we can
have the thing just play the game?
What if we just have it play chess at
five million steps per second per GPU
and then we just run that a whole bunch?
Right? If we get log linear and compute,
we get log linear and compute. Cool, we
win.
And then that's a really awesome end
because uh you know we can test if
algorithmic changes change the shape of
the curve or like get us fundamentally
more efficient so on so forth at
inference.
Oh bollocks to your inference time
scaling that only works with specific MS
like that
you don't need it anyways. You solve
Dota was solved without inference time
scaling there.
Oo.
Hey guys,
Peru is kind of right.
Yo, look at this. We're at 11.5 mil.
Wait, if I do eight, does it get better?
No, it does not get better with eight.
All right, that's too many buffers.
But dude, that's awesome.
Cuz if I do it without this, it gets
worse, right?
Because that's not what we're trying to
do, Ethan. Because we're not just trying
to solve chess, you see.
We're not just trying to solve the
chest. Okay, guys. We actually got this
thing to freaking We nailed it.
Good job, Karu.
Can you explain what I'm doing now or
the chess thing?
The chess thing is very simple. You
cannot run search
on arbitrary environments
and there's no reasonable way to be able
to run search on many environments that
we care about. What did we change? So
Peru had this thing where you uh
technically all the buffers can run in
parallel and they run parallel over the
sequence.
Uh so I did that with OpenMPP and it
looks better. I actually wonder now if I
can use more threads. It probably
scales.
Hang on. Maybe it scales with more
threads now.
Search can't fly a drone. There you go.
And you don't need search to fly a drone
either. What you need is one fin.
and one Sam as well.
Yo, Finn, we got uh we are over 11 mil
now.
>> [laughter]
>> Oh, look at that.
11.8.
I hit 12.5 at the end for a second
there.
That's damn over 11.5 mil.
OQR flies a drone. One fin flies a drone
as well with a tiny little neural net.
You don't have to plan anything.
Planning is a meme.
Oh, this is good.
Okay, I am kind of surprised that this
thing worked.
The funny thing is we can actually make
this even faster once we figure out how
to mess with um the torch puda streams.
But at the I don't know if this is the
best thing to do, but at the least it
was better than the mess that I had
before.
Let's see if it does more with more
threads.
What was the improvement? I stole this
idea from Peru for transparency.
So Peru had this idea. I would have
never come up with this idea on my own
in a million years. So, let's give him
some credit. So, um, Peru's idea was
that you,
uh, you roll out in parallel. So, all
your buffers, they actually can all be
going at the same time without doing
them like roundroin. And this made no
sense to me because the whole point in
my head was that like you know by the
time you've done one forward pass you
have more data waiting for you. Uh but
actually the thing is then what happens
is you're basically like trying to
manually tune the buffer sizes to the
CPU sizes. Whereas with this if like if
you have both buffers ready you can run
both net forward passes. If you have uh
both forward passes done you can run
both end steps in parallel. So, it's
really it's just an additional axis of
parallelism and there's really not much
more to it than that and I just
massively overthought. Um, so yeah, very
very nice
20 mil at this rate. Finn, it actually
might because we still haven't done
BF-16.
And uh the guy that did all the kernel
improvements, like the the last couple
kernel improvements, who got us one or
two, I think he got us like one 1.5 mil
SPS. Um so that guy is
uh working on BF-16. I kind of outlined
it for him, like the thing I was trying
before, and it'll probably work.
Ah, okay. So, this one's like faults.
We'll have to figure that out.
Oh yeah, there's one other thing we can
try.
SPS next to star history.
That'd be funny. We'd have to go
benchmark it for a few different ones.
This one is worse.
No, it's about the same.
Okay. If you make it too small, it gets
worse.
World model stand.
You know, we are actually using them for
something in a research collab we have
going, but it's not for the thing that
you'd think to use them for.
I'll say that much.
Uh, actually, at what point is this
solved in the eval here?
10. Yeah. Sub 10 seconds. That's 10
seconds solve. We win. GG.
Uh there is actually a reasonable thing
to do with world models for driving, but
again it's not the thing that you would
think of.
Well, let's commit everything. We win
today.
and I'm going to go check when dinner
is.
So, my family's getting dinner.
on my AI paper.
Hot is full. One sec.
All right, I got dinner in a few
minutes. Um,
let us just real quick.
That's still crazy to me this works,
Spencer. 11.8 million goddamn SPS. We
win today.
And it's even better than that because
it's an Envmebeck win.
And that's the big bottleneck right now.
I am fried from all this stuff today
though, let me tell you.
It's like five hours of banging my head
against the end of SPS test and then a
few hours of like different possible
ways to redo the event.
We do add the OpenMP dependency, which
is not my favorite,
but that's like a pretty simple one.
And the actual code ends up being way
like way shorter and easier.
I'm getting dinner and a few, but um
I've been live for uh eight hours.
I've also made a bit of a mess of the
code. So, Thursday is going to be like
clean up the code day.
the tests. Like these throwaway tests
are going to have to be mostly thrown
away and done correctly.
Yeah. So, like my idea with all this
like letting Claude do all this crap is
that we're going to end up deleting most
of this because we ultimately only need
the fast path.
So, we've got like four different paths
right now. So, we'll only need the fast
path and then I can manually like clean
up the remaining code.
world model to infinite on Paul.
No, that's not my idea. That's just how
it works. But it's kind of crap. Holy.
Uh,
okay guys,
I think that's a little bit better. What
about you?
Y.
All right, Peru, you rock, man.
Yeah, you kind of rock. I was wrong. My
bad.
This idea is good. I am dumb. I admit
it.
I'm just happy we freaking use this
thing now.
I don't know how it's faster this way. I
must just be trolling.
Yeah, I probably am just like trolling
the overhead.
What did we say cap was? 80 mil.
So, this goes up to 60.
And what with four threads we get
48,
I think we said cap was 80 though guys
because like watch this 118 * 4 okay and
then we have 48 gigs is what we profiled
this machine
Okay, so we're I think that this says
no, but that says that the maximum
memory bandwidth possible for this if
you're just doing transfers
uh should be 100 mil, right?
Oh, wait. Are we profiling on GPU or
not? Here.
right, I got to go, guys. I got to get
dinner. We'll continue this uh on
Thursday. If you want to help me out for
absolutely free, this puffer likes
stars. Feed him a star on GitHub. We're
almost to 5,000. I've been slacking a
little bit on X and stuff because we've
been working on things. So yeah, come
on, help me out. Feed him some stars.
Almost there. Uh, I stream all my dev.
You can join Discord if you want to get
involved. You can follow me on X for
more content now and again, sometimes
articles. I need